bootleg cat podcast special guest
representing the Bronx yeah Connie
diamond is here yeah I'll be outside
what's going on baby uh what part of the
Bronx you're from Fordham
you say I was I showed you I was hanging
out in the Bronx with Ron suno who's a
wild man
in a good way
and I guess I was by your house yeah he
was he was in the area I had a good
chopped cheese over there you did how
you like guitar cheese
I mean I had it I think the way you just
order it and I liked it no it's many
different ways to order it but that was
your first one I think I had some sort
of special ketchup with it is it like a
ketchup mixed with something Mayo
that ain't special that's that's the
order it was good yeah yeah it's always
good yeah shopping uh you just went
viral um LeBron James just reposted your
freestyle with uh over to Luda [__] yeah
he did that's pretty crazy
shout out to LeBron we outside they like
LeBron like hit you and be like yo
you're dope or did you just like wake up
one day and you're like oh [__] LeBron
posting my [__] yeah that's exactly how
it happened I wasn't like a group called
my team and it was like oh [__] LeBron
posted you and I was like that it's
crazy
like for you and your sound because I
think when we think of New York right
now we think of drill yeah would you
consider yourself to be in that lane
because I feel like lyrically you're
a little above that Lane obviously I'm a
thousand percent not a drill artist but
I do come in all the artists that are
coming out right now that I don't
remember but I I'm not your artist I'm
like I'm a well-rounded overall you
could do it all yes I've been doing this
for a long time so yeah you've been
doing it for a bit how long you've been
rapping
um
but yeah for a long time huh I've been
sorry for a long time I'm a very long
time 10 years maybe okay you're like a
OG I'm an OG yeah you're a young OG yeah
like Travelers yeah there's no way
you're definitely younger than fabulous
for the record fabulous ages like
Pharrell
there's no way fabulous isn't 46 years
old right now I I don't know how old but
I mean ages so well you would never know
like fabulous has been rapping since I
was 10 years old and I'm 36. yeah he
outside shout out to Fab
um before we get it started uh I want to
know who's on your Mount Rushmore of
Bronx Hip Hop
Bronx hip-hop oh my God
it's it's a lot of people right now and
like I come to my all time all time all
the time oh I'm gonna say Remy Ma gonna
see Fat Joe
um
Squad
I arrest one oh my god
um cardi B might be in there cardi B is
definitely in there too she's in there
she's the only thing she's she's more in
a newer side but she's still doing her
thing
um I wanted one more I'll give you a
fifth a fifth Mount Rushmore spot even
though that doesn't exist on the real
Mount Rushmore there's only four heads
will tell me give it to me it's got to
be KRS one okay we can add him in there
I mean I'm just a blast Master okay yeah
we got how many I'm just saying like I
thought we was just going by like when I
um for not what I was into when I was
growing up see now you you did the
opposite of Aging yourself you let us
know you're not that old is that fair
shout out to well who else then
um
I have some more artists but then off in
the Bronx
yeah what about right now right now [__]
I like I spice I like her a lot I like
um
I like some drill artists they're all
over the place I only wanting to name
certain ones because I don't because you
don't get it'd be like beef oh you from
this side you like this one like I don't
know you know what I like about ice
patch she's just having fun yes it is
you know you barely see her when you see
it when it's time to work that's it
she's just having fun hanging out with
the Kardashian kids and [__] right you
know what I mean uh what do you got on
the way I got an EP dropping really soon
I gotta know single dropping soon
I can't say I haven't told anybody yet I
don't want to tell anybody Remy Martin I
wish have you met her I've met her yes
she invited me to perform at one of her
uh Battle Raps she's like the nicest
lady of all time she's a sweetheart yeah
her and Papoose are great shout out to
them man yeah I love them well listen uh
EP on the way do we know the name of the
EP yet
I mean you know it but I'm gonna tell
you on the side though we know when it's
coming yeah like sometime next month
okay so in the month of May yes all
right well let's get to These Bars let's
get to it baby
[Music]
time I was never the plan team in person
hit the Running Man like pillows talking
these [__] it's better every smoke
put a [__] in the Swisher bring it a
premium don't blame it on liquor I'm at
the big trying to break me a [__] like
what [__] Ain't sliding [__] get I be
demon on time those Milwaukee demons go
riding carbon copy [__] be lying how
this [__] in my city I'm geeking hit
the snooze only see him all weekend I
get decisions
be eating right in the [__] chin and he
said he was dumb but he spent again he
ain't calling me toxic I get it in he
ain't running his pockets I get his
friend I ain't ducking no smoke big
Trisha Connie Diamond [__] nice to meet
you why you [__] be stuck on the
bleachers in the field home [__] my
cleats have call me the reaper like God
keep it up being before with smoke all
you [__] fans that's what time I was
never the plan see him in person hit the
Running Man like pillow talking these
[__] is better if it smoke
[Music]
you got the new song out with Ken the
man right now go run that up new music
coming EP and Max EPM may we outside
shout out to the Bronx yeah hey stay out
of all that Bronx big bro then I'm glad
to see you're disconnected from the
Bronx politics
I like it yeah there it is appreciate
you pulling up of course thank you let's
get to it boom hey I know you just
watched the new freestyle guess what
we're dropping them every week sometimes
more than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week